yeah I feel so close to you yeah me too
hey GQ is your girl Teyana Taylor and
I'm here to see how well my lovely
husband knows it's the GQ couples grab
the first set of questions here how much
ammo you got over there Jesus Wow really
loaded her up first question what's the
first meal I've ever cooked for you
macaroni and cheese she had to teach me
how she like a good dude man
I never made macaroni but I'll be like
it was it was a nice effort it was cute
it was good oh you know this one how
many tattoos do I have you don't see any
part of my body there you go one two
three four five six seven eight
man you think you got it I think none to
you oh the new one Junie yeah give me
double ease about cuz I don't have any
tattoos you got you go exactly two
points my way let's go what's my
favorite color really you know points do
you know what time it is what was my
first job ever
technically Star Trek right
yeah technically I don't know if you had
like one off
you could have been like Star Trek would
go first though I'm falling right now
what's going for do you know if I call
need one thing for the rest of my life
what would it be only pick one one and
get it right mac and cheese you know
this right yeah what's something on my
bucket list
so Father's Day I took more than
Ellicott well like what's my long what's
on my like long term bucket list the
helicopter is like oh we've seen it
we're gonna get it was like really on my
bucket list to turn one of your concerts
into the Broadway how do you know what
I'm mad at you
you can start going deep answer your
phone like you usually just be on the
phone for do it where you mad you like
this your hair to magically go over your
face but act like you go do you don't
get a point for that one cuz you ain't
answer I'm closing my eyes what color my
eyes it's like a black coffee with like
a drop of cream and a little bit of
sugar on the side white cane sugar if
you want to be coffee Colorama yeah they
called me coffee yes my cell phone
number until
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the fourth one
I feel so close that's before that's
crazy yeah like that was really good
like you might be MVP of like this
couples quiz thing how long does it take
me to do my makeup anywhere from
anywhere from like 45 to an hour 30
that's a fact
cuz I'm people be like three hours and
I'm like yeah
it depends though it varies for this for
me 45 to 30 that's not bad at all
no she don't go back can't go all the
way I like what it's two quick ones
where she just put on the natural thing
that she do she do like this do we look
oh it's a good one what's my favorite
fast food and what do I like to order
there it what's my favorite my favorite
dipping my little ding I like to dip
much of your shoe sir you still get a
point okay well that's hard
you don't know black and ranch no no
yeah I know I know they happen yeah it's
new house but God does beti does beti
who wear my musical influences when I
was growing up Janet what's her full
name you call her by her full name Jenny
Jenny imma do don't we that's what we
call her oh she made it to a first name
basis
miss Jackson well you talk about a bit
Jackson what was MTV show I appeared on
in my teen years hmm was it my 16 she
thought I didn't like I was lying about
not seeing it and then I actually
watched it now say you pick the bike oh
[ __ ] oh my little thing like bro you
picked a bike you know better don't wait
girl what the range that was crazy one
person wrote a comment was like um oh
yeah
Tiana sailor was that was that sporty
bra 2016 a prank bro what it was like
all I want it will go right mind you if
you notice only got mad one time in a
what was because I didn't get the
headboard ramp and it was a skateboard
pardon so you know I'm after I get to
clear that up because I was not the
spoil you Brett this first part we might
want to whup my ass okay uh uh what's
the best way to make me mad
those ladies
you got a few adults get into ritual
abuse oh my god I do not play social
media games he's like he's like well I
think I knew that'd get your attention
if I did it on social media
describe me in three words
beautiful daring entrepreneur she never
heard it put together she's starting to
like actually see what I did
[Music]
what I'm most comfortable sleeping in
know if I wasn't in music or fashion
what would I do
she wasn't an entertainment yeah
probably do interior decorating the
escape borders oh no that's a fact
well not when I go and I got signed when
I got cited Pharrell he was like all
right teeth you know I'm all here for
skateboarders I'm here for it but you
gonna have to chill you don't need your
legs all [ __ ] up and you get injured
and you got an album to me that was the
day that's not skateboarding
oh that's the reason why mm-hmm what's
awesome
Darnell's own album where I want to be
this cute and Justin Bieber you know
definitely substance and for determine
just leave that to Justin
what am I most scared of you know what
I'm gonna be Jordan would it be to this
feel like I'll get drifted away
are you drifted away for sure what's my
coffee order it's not really a thing
it's like strawberry and cream yeah yeah
some Starbucks but it's Starbucks coffee
shop right so my coffee order just
strawberries and cream what is my middle
name
mrs. a clean so that's crazy cheery
lightly you don't say no because she put
it mjo Heidi harmless you don't saying I
can only do so much who's my favorite
actor slash actress that's tough though
you got a couple of so it's either this
is a Sarah just say I don't know whether
to throw a hell you're jaded this is
this yoga yeah oh god who is it
oh I never would have guessed that I
know of your goats
y'all got yeah everybody misses everyone
finally finally where was I born Harlem
what's the name of my first album
who is my celebrity crush so it's this
guy right and he's a people to mix it up
I kind of liked him better when he
played for the [ __ ] eating mad dumps
anyway his name is Iman shrimp or some
[ __ ] like that
always hard to pronounce his last name
so always try to pronounce his last name
but I'll go any one day maybe me take me
on a date
let's throw your score on this your
screen I found you officially MVP a
couple squares or GQ
[Applause]